I'll tell you what he can shoot the
basketball
people shoot the basketball this is
where you ought to be some of the
athleticism Erica
[Applause]
Austin Rivers pumps up a three
[Applause]
it will have the lead at the break the
question will be by how much
[Applause]
Magruder is a savvy player how do you
defend that well I mean my thing is this
how many times do you see people block
30 points up shots you can see the
defense that big nerds is trying to
employ this year
Westbrook up top for capela Westbrook
drives into a double teaming dumps it
off for Tyson Chandler as few minutes
but the Rockets in front here in Tokyo
[Music]
and there's a player playing right now
the Rockets are giving after the coop
hold the shot they would in the playoffs
and that's also looking for a foul three
defenses we're going to see rust knock
down his first three-pointer as a rocket
Tom Brady seen every defense in the last
time after the pupal had the ball on
Tucker he scored on the jump hook and
looked at me and said this is too easy
and that was too easy of a block right
there for hardly try to stay in front of
pardon normally a Roberson as that test
zeroes in be a difference about six
second shot clock gating clock are you
working on Gallinari will shoot over it
[Applause]
where he's gonna go and hard and lays it
up the apartment for Marty got a dance
harden gonna shoot Hart's gonna score
that would look good
argit
deep step back and make but two and a
half to go to straight hoops goes it
will counts Westbrook with the running
midcourt Heath and the Rockets are down
twenty-eight prouder old blue more comes
out Martin's just does get to it shot
clock about to go off though use it the
capela screen leans in
[Applause]
our will lost to Miami in Miami Sunday
can beat the Memphis Grizzlies on Monday
first bucket of the game for Houston
Bauman season-opening stolen by
Westbrook great anticipation by
Westbrook rivers the trail at little
fake got rid of Bowman three
quarterbacks go three for three from
downtown for Austin Rivers been to the
bowl starting line of this entire season
Westbrook turns it over then gets it
right back and then houses why don't
look at the quarter it hits another tray
better way to drive like capela blocked
that one as well here's Westbrook what
on three
[Applause]
Westbrook's got a cappella 8 straight
for Houston this pass between hardens
legs prove a few possessions ago what a
great pass through his own five hole
through the pocket there to capella for
the dump he's probably gonna spend some
time moving back and forth but Otto
Porter is out with a foot sprain and
dunk it down how about that pass look at
this over the top pass capella is open
so hardens got to find a way to get
George bad pass and hardens gonna have
the easiest two of the night for him
else to give both in the penalty under
two to play harden step back puts up the
three got hit chats good James Harden
double team that a chance for a
four-point play easily could be one of
the top five teams in the league capella
outside
and Russell hits a three Russell
Westbrook with a three timeout on the
court
rockets trail by 11 quick attack by
James Harden boys a very solid coach
gets his players to play hard steal by
Harden
he's got Westbrook he hits it at a 40%
slip as a starter and the Rockets are
off the launching pad
hard drives dumps oh baby another look
at the drive and slam for James Harden
third years look at harden he's got two
guys on him he knows he's got homes on
him so Capella's got to be open
somewhere the woodland Church super-mo
shows you what a great pass over the
shoulder that was to compel us
[Applause]
turning on the Jets
[Music]
[Applause]
to shop with Western he went bye buddy
he like you were standing in mud and
that's what Westbrook brings to the
rocket
Westbrook into the lane shot clock down
to three harden on the move the floater
beats the shot clock and regains the
lead for Houston lot of Orlando players
[Applause]
let's see it part it combo combining for
16 in the first and right into your
living room Westbrook with the flush
Marta Williams into the paint step
through a rivers blocked by Harden three
second to play in the third barn one on
three to beat the buzzer or did hinge
really good and here's a look at that
last second shot Matt as he split the
double-team in oh yeah
plenty of time look at that floater from
about 15 feet swish 10 made threes for
the Spurs in the first half
Ardi puts it up and he hits at the
buzzers James Harden so a season high 72
first-half points by the San Antonio
Spurs and they have taken charge of the
first part of this game go for the pump
fake make sure you make the player earn
it
and here's harden squeezing by and
scores 56
[Applause]
still with it goes in to beat the shot
clock there's two threes ago where it
was really struggling to get the ball to
dribble right and then he just had to
shoot it up as the shot keeps it alive
to Russell Westbrook dances on Hill gets
to the rim and it rolls in
[Applause]
and strip defense by Russell Stein steps
up to stop Dinwiddie and Russ able to
get back from behind Paris had him
partially blind Russell on the run
advanced passed by harden to Westbrook
who emphatically slams it home it's
always in that way
as harden has 22 points and 10 rebounds
and he nails a three and he towns being
out and he's really showing that he's
got some years ago and then it'll come
back to us and we'll find a way to get
it done again
Willard mentions past experience and one
for Westbrook
[Applause]
trying to go behind his back right -
Craig block by Westbrook that makes up
for in the state I love the way
Whisperer tries to get it back
Thabo sefalosha first Westbrook denies
Craig at the cuff meanwhile Portland
after Carmelo Anthony was fouled by
harden got just one score in its first
10 possession Ariza and his
effectiveness on the defensive end
that's the athleticism look at the ups
those are shots I mean
[Applause]
the rim 21 points 9 in the quarter
definitely thought there was contact as
again rust just soars to the rim pulls
it back 23 points on 12 shots 5 seconds
to go in the half
defended by Josh Hart step-back three
you bet for harden here in the first
half good play by hard Arden's got
healthy there it is to McLemore you
mentioned
[Music]
Russ is on the floor without a big man
he's at his best so that it was the big
driver of why the Rockets made the trade
Drake capella who can figure that how
you put that into context is what
through dealing with right now with the
couple winning Rockets Hardin with the
lane wide open that's a benefit of small
ball fella who was traded to Atlanta but
he said this is the way that we need to
play nor dilute our full potential kids
by four Rockets Celtics poly pulls down
the board Wiggins and the LOB for
Westbrook set up by the beard in San
Francisco the pick harden to Westbrook
best of friends GQ cover boys we're off
and running here in the bay
his own snow gives it up Westbrook late
in the clock gets it off from paddock
scores a little bit range was a great
signing as he's put the last couple of
years with the Pacers Bart dancing on
Clarkson steps right shoots scores I can
to guard that you have to be competitive
to be successful at this level but
Russ's now here is James Hortons lob
over the top to Westwood look at how
high Westbrook gets up off the floor and
the hang time it takes to wait for the
pass wow that was a great pass though
how was I on in the auxilary gym I want
to talk about Westbrook is just pounding
them at the paint and called for a
taunting technical but gets a technical
foul he's bludgeoning them at the basket
[Applause]
competing in the paint not allowing the
Celtics to get a good look at the rim
harden for the lead sputter and Houston
leads it I've just watch how hard how
easy he makes this look now right there
Haywood is right on top of them he even
missed them challenged the shot two
minutes to go harden blows by Tatum it
kicks it out Tucker with the post
replied legs this late in the game just
keep an eye on you come right into your
picture how about that one don't call a
play they know what they want
hopefully to make three to beat the
buzzer in the third quarter
[Applause]
what if in West where he takes the ball
coast-to-coast
turns on the Jets hammers at home the
crowd here in New York went crazy on
that dump lot of Westbrook fans in here
Watson and that is 20 points now for
Russell his 31st game of scoring 20 or
more this match to James once
look at him shading over there to help
him out back in the corner Russell with
a rare three and it goes James Harding
creating a wide open shot for us and you
can see their defender came in to stop
the new the new generation of big men's
in the NBA mobile boys bike that got
long arms just like Capote oh shoot
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content